es ist eine Zahl die schockiert zehn
Prozent Inflation die Preise kennen kein
Halten mehr die jenseits Monaten durch
die Decke im September war das Leben 10%
teurer als letztes Jahr zehn Prozent das
gab es seit fast 70 Jahren nicht mehr
der teuerstock der bremst auch die
Konjunktur für das nächste Jahr fürchten
die Institute dass die
Wirtschaftsleistung um 0,4% schrumpft im
schlimmsten Fall könnte sie sogar 7,9%
einbrechen ebenfalls ein Rekord und wir
wollten wissen wie sieht es bei Ihnen
aus machen sie sich Sorgen Sorgen vor
dem kalten Winter haben sie Angst vor
der Zukunft
das sind immer größere Herausforderungen
und die Fragen werden immer mehr und die
Antworten immer weniger von daher ist ja
ist da einiges zu tun also sorry dreimal
so früh für mein Gas oder für meinen
Strom oder soll ich sechs Mal so viel
und also
ja und das macht einen unzufrieden
aktuell die steigenden Preise man merkt
es auch wirklich an den Gaspreise machen
wenn der Abschlagszahlungen die halt
drastisch erhöht werden es wird halt
immer teurer und teurer und wir wissen
nicht wie wir aus auskommen sozusagen
einfach ob irgendwie mit Atom etwas
kommt dass meine Hauptsache ja ein
bisschen schon aber im Moment geht's
noch ganz normal 14 Cent gewesen dieser
Strom mehr kostet bei zu Hause es geht
noch so
ich habe Angst dass wir es nicht
schaffen und dass wir einen gewaltigen
demonstrationsdruck darauf hinbekommen
Angst ist sowas typisch deutsches gehen
Sie mal ins Ausland sagen wir
vergleichen Sie mal Deutschland mit
England
wenn ich in England wäre da würde ich
Angst bekommen und Zuständen in die
gesamte politische Situation dazu gehört
natürlich auch der Ukraine Krieg wo sich
die Menschen Gedanken machen inwiefern
sich das eventuell sogar noch ausweitet
ja das wäre ein ganz großes Problem ja
welche weltpolitische Lage wegen der
steigen Inflation man weiß nicht wo es
hingeht viele Leute können Ihre Rechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen
die Schere zwischen armen reich wird
aufgehen wenn man irgendwie alleine
wohnt dann ist es schon problematisch so
ein Privatleben schon also gerade auch
im einkaufen und alles das Leben ist
viel teurer geworden
also das spürt man schon es macht einem
Angst das macht einem Angst ja und wir
sind jetzt verbunden mit einer Frau die
genau weiß wie arm Deutschland ist wir
begrüßen circa jenes Geschäftsführerin
der Tafel Deutschland die alle 960
Tafeln vertritt was bedeutet die
Rezeption für Sie für die Tafel jetzt
ja guten Tag zusammen wir machen uns
große Sorgen was den Herbst und den
bestehenden Winter angeht denn schon
über 30 Prozent der Tafeln haben einen
Aufnahmestopp gemeldet können also keine
weiteren Menschen mehr unterstützen
dafür wo wir angetreten sind und wo soll
das noch hingehen wir erwarten wir
müssen also davon ausgehen dass es schon
jetzt viel mehr Menschen sind als die
die wir aktuell unterstützen können und
wir erwarten noch viel mehr wie schwer
ist es aktuell für die Tafeln überhaupt
an Waren zu kommen jetzt wo auch
Supermärkte Discounter damit begonnen
haben waren als noch guttüten an ihre
Kunden noch zu verkaufen
wir sind ja vor 30 Jahren knapp 30
Jahren angetreten
Lebensmittelverschwendung zu reduzieren
insofern begrüßen wir natürlich
grundsätzlich alle Maßnahmen auch die
der Discounter die versuchen
Lebensmittel zu retten und die
Verschwendung zu reduzieren aber ja das
gehört auch dazu in diesen Zeiten wo es
sowieso sehr schwer ist es kommt weniger
bei den Tafeln an die Tafeln brauchen
mehr Lebensmittel was muss die
Bundesregierung machen ihrer Meinung
nach und wie können auch Bürger helfen
was fordern Sie
wir denken dass die Maßnahmen die die
Bundesregierung ergreift schon in die
richtige Richtung gehen es sind ja viele
Maßnahmen geplant jetzt aktuell gestern
wurden weitere verkündet trotzdem sind
sie nicht zielgerichtet genug wir müssen
jetzt wirklich auf die Menschen gucken
die unsere Hilfe brauchen und da müssen
die Hilfen zielgerichtete ankommen das
fordern wir und das wir müssen und das
ist so noch nicht erfolgt es ist noch zu
sehr Gießkannenprinzip von der
Bevölkerung und der Gesellschaft fordern
wir aber auch ein zusammenstehen wir
müssen jetzt alle zusammen stehen es
werden sind schwierige Zeiten und wir
müssen glaube ich ein gesellschaftliches
Solidaritätsgefühl entwickeln wir freuen
uns über Menschen die uns Zeit schenken
die uns ehrenamtlich helfen wir freuen
uns über Lebensmittel spenden wir freuen
uns über Geld und alle die die sich das
leisten können die bitten wir doch auf
die Armutsbetroffenen Menschen zu
schauen und diese auch zu unterstützen
die Tafeln brauchen also mehr
Lebensmittel und Unterstützung
herzlichen Dank für dieses Gespräch sehr
cayenne ist Geschäftsführerin der Tafeln
Deutschland danke ihnen ich danke Ihnen
so was sagt Armutsforscher Professor
Christoph buddhaweger aus Köln dazu Herr
Buddha die Wirtschaft wird
voraussichtlich deutlich schrumpfen
zugleich werden Energie und Lebensmittel
teurer wie viel mehr arme Menschen
werden wir in Deutschland haben
das weiß natürlich niemand so genau weil
Karl Valentin hat gesagt Prognosen sind
schwierig besonders wenn sie die Zukunft
betreffen aber wir haben heute schon ein
Rekordstand der Armut mit Betroffenen
16,6% der Bevölkerung das sind 13,8
Millionen Menschen die weniger als 60
Prozent des mittleren Einkommens zur
Verfügung haben das heißt für einen
alleinstehenden weniger als
1148 Euro im Monat
was sind für Sie die Gründe warum wir in
Deutschland Armut nach wie vor als
selbst schuldproblem abtun jetzt gerade
in dieser Krise die uns auch im Winter
bevorsteht wo immer mehr Menschen von
der Armut betroffen sein könnten
das hat sicher damit zu tun dass über
die Wirtschaftsstrukturen über die
Eigentumsverhältnisse über die
verteilungsmechanismen dieser
Gesellschaft zu wenig gesprochen wird
Leistung wird häufig mit
wirtschaftlichem Erfolg gleichgesetzt
oder man könnte auch sagen verwechselt
und dann ist es natürlich auch so dass
zum Beispiel die Medien viel mehr
berichten über Leistungsmissbrauch den
es gibt aber was ist viel mehr gibt das
arme ganz tolles leisten zum Beispiel
die 500.000 alleinerziehenden Mütter im
Hartz IV Bezug dass die über den Monat
kommen auch wenn sie am 20 des Monats
vielleicht gar nicht mehr wissen wie sie
noch was Warmes auf den Tisch bekommen
sollen für ihre Kinder das wird in der
Öffentlichkeit viel zu wenig
ernst genommen zur Kenntnis genommen und
ich fände es wäre angesagt den Arm mehr
Verständnis entgegenzubringen und sie
nicht sozial auszugrenzen
es gibt die Bewegung ich bin armuts
betroffen kann die tatsächlich etwas
verändern
ja Armut ist nicht ansteckend aber die
Betroffenen werden in unserer
wohlhabenden wenn ich reichen
Gesellschaft oft wie Aussätzige
behandelt und dieser Hashtag ich bin
armuts betroffen der ändert jetzt
insofern was als die soziale Ausgrenzung
die Isolation auf dieser Menschen die
leiden ja nicht nur daran dass sie wenig
Geld haben sie haben auch wenig soziale
Kontakte und Möglichkeiten sich in die
Gesellschaft einzubringen weil sie eben
eher verachtet und verächtlich gemacht
wird dieser Hashtag führt jetzt dazu
dass Sie sich das erste Mal in die
Öffentlichkeit begeben dass sie sich
trauen dass sie sich zusammenschließen
dass sie sich vernetzen dass sie sich
organisieren und das halte ich für einen
ganz ganz wichtigen Schritt um gegen
Armut und soziale Ungleichheit in
Deutschland etwas zu bewirken denn nur
wenn die Betroffenen mitsprechen nur
wenn die sich auch engagieren nur dann
kann man dieses Problem denke ich lösen
Arme darf man nicht sozial ausgrenzen
sagt Christoph budderwege Armutsforscher
vielen Dank dass er sich hier heute
Mittag die Zeit genommen haben bitte
schön
[Musik]